today we're going to play co-op
all right you guys ready
follow me all right oh please fan yeah
let's do this let's do this there's a
police van so you want to open it yeah I
would love to but as you can see there
lots of them here but there is a gas
tank if we explode the gas tank then
that should be here I'm gonna I'm gonna
lure them with firecrackers so somebody
go for the gas tank yeah he's already
going miss what it is I'm going to open
it please put that cover you
we'll cover you it's a very hard
lockpick it's not going to be easy
yeah I'm close I'm close I'm getting
closer yeah that's good surprise holy
buildable zombie I'm so in I am so in as
it is thanks to this guy and I'm gonna
cheat as hell because I've got a
freaking gun headshot headshot nice
I'm out of ammo pal
normally I would help you oh there's a
competition to kill the rice soldiers
now we can do we can do the Navy SEALs
action okay I get ready I've got a gun I
can snipe one on three one two three
this is how I roll man
that's how I roll do you see that this
step they fighting before though oh man
trying a gas tank can you shoot it okay
ready ready one two three
hey get the look get the look then let's
get out of here okay guys so I think we
found a bolter those guys have some
really rare loot so I guess let's try it
to try to take it down okay oops I
spilled it i spooked it up
I throw nitro I'm right behind him I'm
right behind him
nice okay that was a nice kid though he
landed in the most awkward spot the
vault I'm let's get out of here
let's get out of here run
stop going down I won't help you guys I
won't help you okay I gotta call the
title me being came clear well at least
one of us will make it alright where I
could go out and get you guys by will I
hello there how old on the tower you
know what guys I have a problem take it
it's all of us just standing in the
carrion watching come on
hey that's me can you see me yeah he's
almost here just just one more here
alright high fives all around
alright I think that's it for today yeah
sure hope you guys enjoyed it
cool it was great love this differently
alright thank you so much see you next
time
hey guys here I come you ready yeah I'm
ready
guess what guys wanna play